aquí no crea ya no se han abierto en las
últimas horas nuevos frentes de batalla
hoy hemos amanecido con un número de
ataques registrados inferior al de los
pasados días y también el ejército
ucraniano ha informado que sus tropas
siguen resistiendo al avance ruso una
información también confirmada desde
eeuu y en un momento en el que las
negociaciones parecen haberse estancado
el presidente de ucrania blow dormirse
lens que sigue buscando a la desesperada
nuevos aliados y también nuevos
mediadores que puedan resolver esta
crisis el presidente francés emmanuel
macrón le ha respondido que él está
dispuesto a asumir este papel siempre y
cuando se pacte un alto al fuego
preocupa en cambio las noticias que
llegan desde moscú un portavoz del
kremlin ha dicho que su país no descarta
el uso de las armas nucleares en el caso
de que rusia se sintiese amenazada